this morning we continued our real food
series looking at new ways food is being
grown and prepared in the case of bread
it might make people feel a little less
guilty to indulge John Blackstone met a
baker who's on a mission to make
delicious bread that's also packed with
important nutrients at San Francisco's
popular Tartine bakery the smell of
fresh bread can draw a crowd as long as
I'm making bread there's always
something new for me to learn Chad
Robertson tartines co-owner and chief
bread baker is part of a movement to get
Americans to stop thinking about bread
as a guilty pleasure by changing the way
it's made what most of this country has
been eating is is a really refined you
know fast processed bread that just it
doesn't have much flavor and it doesn't
have much nutrition to make better break
he uses something that for now is hard
to find in America freshly milled flour
that is not stripped of grains vital
nutrient milling fresh flour is just
like grinding fresh coffee or fresh
spices it's a much fresher sort of
stronger flavor and aroma depending on
what grains we're using and what kind of
bread were making we'll give you this
very flavorful really digestible highly
nutritious loaf of bread in the end now
you may be thinking Robertson is just
another San Francisco foodie pushing
another artisanal fad but he's just one
of a group of bakers around the country
changing the way they make bread and
science is on their side
he'll recognize a sort of all-purpose
flour your normal sort of pure white
flour
David Killa lay as a scientist at
Children's Hospital Oakland Research
Institute so in the white flour that
we're accustomed to when you tested that
there was there's not much there it's
it's mostly sugar all-purpose white
flour was developed during
industrialization to extend shelf life
but to make it last months or even years
two main components of the wheat must be
discarded the bran and the germ and that
means losing most of the vitamins
minerals and fiber looking at the iron
copper zinc calcium and is a really big
difference when you go from all-purpose
which doesn't have very many of the
minerals to the whole grain which has
much more of it sometimes double for
zinc four times the amount of zinc six
to eight times the amount of manganese
and all those minerals are essential for
health but the author of the
best-selling book Wheat Belly dr.
William Davis told CBS this morning that
replacing white flour products with
whole grains is simply replacing
something harmful with something
slightly less harmful and it doesn't
mean that whole grains are good for you
bread has had a pretty bad reputation
for a while yes right now it's
definitely looked upon suspiciously but
at least in my opinion a lot of that has
to do with the way that the bread is
made if we could get people eating whole
grains we would do a lot to address the
actual missing nutrients in our
population but getting more whole grains
into the American diet means changing
the way flour is milled distributed and
stored Chad Robertson is working on that
encouraging the development of more
local small batch flour mills Coffee is
a really good example that I always go
back to I mean 20 years ago what do you
think that everyone to be grinding
coffee fresh in their house all over the
country people you know know what fresh
ground coffee tastes lag and that was a
relatively quick transition with the
opening of his newest San Francisco
restaurant the manufacturing Robertson
hopes to be part of a similar transition
to a day when it's not necessary to go
to a high-end bakery to get bread this
good
and this good for you really all you
have to do is taste it and then it's
pretty easy after that for CBS this
morning John Blackstone San Francisco
let them eat bread I could tell by the
way cut it the way it was crunchy and
soft yeah we know that sound
we love that sound